[Music]
politics and food may not makes at the
dinner table during the holidays but
that's certainly not the case on the
campaign trail Ed O'Keefe has traveled
across the country with 2020
presidential hopefuls for months and why
is food such a hot topic on the campaign
trail Oh Joe Rica because it's
everywhere one thing we've noticed
throughout this past year out on the
trail is that food is one of the ways
candidates are drawing voters in by
appearing at events where food is the
main attraction or by serving it up
themselves sometimes the candidate
serves it up just right but campaigning
with food can also be a high-stakes
gamble in South Carolina it's fish Iowa
it's steak or corn dogs in New Hampshire
they serve up politics and eggs the
candidate speaks and then signs wood and
eggs anywhere you go with the candidates
there's cameras and catering it helps
draw a crowd fuels the campaign and
offers the candidate a chance to connect
with people let's not flounder let's get
out there and kick some bass the big
thing with food is the idea that it
tells us important things about who you
are Emily Conte why is a food and media
scholar at the University of Tulsa who
studies the intersection of food and
politics with a presidential candidate
the hope is that by getting to eat with
this person or seeing them eat a food
from your local area that you get a
better sense of who they are as a person
but sometimes watching a politician eat
can leave a bad taste in the mouths of
voters remember when Gerald Ford ate a
tamale without removing the husk or when
George HW Bush said he didn't like
broccoli and I haven't liked it since I
was a little kid and I'm President of
the United States and I'm not gonna eat
any more broccoli where that time Gary
Bauer fell off a New Hampshire stage
while flipping pancakes
when John Kerry ordered Swiss cheese on
his Philly cheesesteak the City of
Brotherly Love loathed him and recently
Pete Buddha Jed's got fried online for
slicing a cinnamon roll than eating it
like a chicken wing my hope is that
instead of as harping on candidates when
they make these mistakes is that we
encourage them to ask questions right
when you go into a restaurant that
you've never been to before to say I
haven't had this but I'm so excited to
try it over the summer we stopped in
Columbia South Carolina at the
world-famous Kleiber and fish fry hosted
by House Majority Whip Jim Clyburn it
was his largest ever more than 4,400
fish sandwiches served for thousands of
voters there to see nearly two dozen
candidates there we go moment of truth
that is good oh of course you did in
Iowa the State Fair is a must stop for
any presidential contender there's corn
dogs to eat pork chops to flip and ice
cream to lick in September candidates
headed back to Iowa for a local
Democratic steak front and this weekend
you're catering for 10,000 attendees how
many of these steak fries have you been
to through the years while voters eat
candidates flip steaks and buy the beer
and try to prove they've got what it
takes are the crowds coming for the
politicians are they coming for the food
I think the politicians are like ala
mode senator Amy Klobuchar thinks that
catching up with voters over a meal is
essential for any politician they may do
it over a root beer float or over a tiny
Tim donut but they talk to you and
that's what you want to have as a
politician you don't want to become so
insulated that the only people you hear
from are on Twitter feed and that's why
I think it's so important to go to
things like state fairs and eat the food
with the people we got lots of tips from
the candidates about how they handle
food when the campaigning senator
Klobuchar for example told us her
strategy is to avoid buying big servings
herself and instead just try bites of
everything she's offered by voters nice
Edie
I know in your piece the experts said
it's all about being able to get a sense
of who people are through the food that
they eat so who are you ad what
on the campaign well it's not just me
jurika we polled our producers are
hard-working campaign reporters in Iowa
New Hampshire South Carolina who travel
with the candidates all over the country
said guys remind me what is it you are
eating in between events as you try to
fuel your day among other things the
Albanese gummy bears these are my go-to
during a debate especially beef jerky if
you haven't tried a pickle in a bag I
highly recommend it
take me seriously here folks its
vegetables its salt you're driving it's
great one of our guys Alex was based out
in the West pointed out that he has
easily downed several bananas during
long trips between events and at the end
of the day several of them admitted they
liked a good bottle of wine O'Keefe
report on the average weight gain so you
can very easily if you're not careful
you can very easily gain several yes and
then the odd number you're afterward is
to you you just starve yourself I guess
Happy New Year mr. okay happy new to
guys take care
you